how much of that is you playing master  of puppets  it's pretty much all of me i've played  guitar since i was quite young so i had  kind of the foundations that take most  of it it's great fun you know who  wouldn't want to be a rock star for the  afternoon well i think it might be the  only world where like a sequence like  that can exist and it not feel  ridiculous i mean obviously it is  ridiculous but it feels earned and it  feels fun and it feels like the perfect  crescendo for this crazy sequence were  you aware of the amount of love that  eddie has yeah i got a text from the  doctors a couple of weeks ago saying  kind of we're bracing ourselves it's a  completely overwhelming feeling i did  it's so lovely like the devotion that  the fans have for the show and kind of  how they've found space in their heart  for a new character it's heartwarming  they've been so gracious and welcoming  it's lovely